you gave a D minus the economist so are
they too like the politicians to wash in
terms of there's good ideas and bad
ideas and and that tiny Delta between
good and and bad is how you squeak past
the f plus onto the D minus territory
I think most economic ideas are bad
ideas like most you know like um take us
back to MIT and you want to solve a
fluid dynamics problem like like design
the shape of the Hall of that ship or
you want to design an airfoil a wing or
if you want to design an engine or a a
nozzle and a rocket ship you wouldn't do
it with simple arithmetic you wouldn't
do it with a scalar there's not a single
number right it's vect it's Vector math
you know computational fluid dynamics is
n-dimensional
higher level math you know complicated
stuff
so when when an economist says the
inflation rate is two percent that's a
scalar and when an economist says
it's not a problem to print more money
because the velocity of the money is
very low the monetary velocity is low
that's another scalar
okay so the truth of the matter is
inflation is not a scale or inflation is
an indimensional vector
money velocity is not a scalar
um
saying what's the velocity of money oh
oh it's slow or it's fast it ignores the
question of what medium is the money
moving through in the same way that you
know what's the speed of sound
okay well what is sound right
sound you know sound is uh is a
compression Wave It's energy moving
through a medium but the speed is
different so for example the speed of
sound through air is different than the
speed of sound through water and and a
sound moves faster through water it
moves faster through a solid and it
moves faster to a stiffer solid so there
isn't one what is the fundamental
problem with the way economists reduce
the world down to a model is it too
simple or is it just even the first
principles of constructing the model is
wrong I think that uh the fundamental
problem is
if you see the world as a scalar you
simply pick the one number which is
which supports whatever you want to do
and you ignore the universe of other
consequences from your behavior in
general I don't know if you've heard of
um the air quest that has been talking
about this with Gage Theory so different
different kinds of approaches from the
physics World from the mathematical
world to extend past this
scalar view of Economics so gauge theory
is one way that comes from physics do
you find that
a way of exploring economics interesting
so outside of cryptocurrency outside of
the actual Technologies and so on just
uh analysis of how economics Works do
you find that interesting
yeah I I think that if we're going to
want to really make any scientific
progress in economics we have to apply
much much more computationally intensive
and richer forms of mathematics so
simulation perhaps or yeah you know when
I was at MIT I studied System Dynamics
uh you know they taught it uh the Sloan
school it was developed by Jay Forrester
who who um was an extraordinary computer
scientist and um when we've created
models of economic behavior they were
all multi-dimensional non-linear models
so if you want to describe how anything
works in the real world you have to
start with the concept of feedback if I
double the price of something demand
will fall and attempts to to create
Supply will increase and there will be a
delay before the capacity increases
there'll be an ends of demand change and
they'll be Rippling effects throughout
every other segment of the economy
Downstream and Upstream of such thing so
it's kind of common sense but most
economics most classical economics it's
always you know taught with linear
models
you know fairly simplistic linear models
and oftentimes even I'm really shocked
today
that the entire mainstream dialogue of
economics has been captured by scalar
arithmetic
for example if if you read uh you know
read any article in New York Times or
the Wall Street Journal right they just
refer to it there's an inflation number
or the the CPI or the inflation rate is
X and if you look at all the historic
studies of the impact of inflation
generally they're all based upon the
idea that inflation equals CPI and then
they try to extrapolate from that and
you just get nowhere with it
so at the very least we should be
considering inflation and other
economics concept is a nonlinear
dynamical system so non-linearity and
also just embracing the full complexity
of just how the variables interact maybe
through simulation maybe some
have some interesting models around that
wouldn't it be refreshing if somebody
for once published a table of the change
in price of every product every service
and every asset and every place over
time